[Music]
hello everyone and welcome we are here
it's Wednesday right I've been doing the
last couple days after e3 week I was
just so knocked off course fitting who
what's up everybody perched here and I'm
joined by Alessandro today we're gonna
be playing some blood stain ritual
tonight and if you guys don't know about
this game it is made from some of the
same creators it's Castlevania right and
a lot of people kind of consider this
like the successor to that series pretty
much this is basically like a sort of a
return to form for the you know
Castlevania series in some way like a
lot of people have been yearning for
like a sort of like a return to light
the so called ego vania which is in
reference to the sort of one of the more
prolific designers of Castlevania whose
Igarashi left left Konami and created
his own company too and started a
Kickstarter campaign back reign I
believe 2015 it wasn't this like the
most expensive like Kickstarter funded
before Shenmue I mean it just took off
like almost immediately because a lot of
people were definitely yearning for like
that sort of very familiar like us ego
vania or more popularly known as the
metroidvania cell gosh yeah yeah I mean
I saw a little bit of gameplay on this
nothing too much but it looks really
really good um you know been luckily had
this on his Steam account and let us
download it thank goodness so we're
gonna be playing on PC today but it's
available also on ps4 and it's coming to
switch on Tuesday I think so it's coming
to all these platforms and yeah it's
very exciting we're gonna jump into it
I'm gonna turn the volume up just a
little bit because the music's very nice
and welcome everyone I see some familiar
faces in the chat so chill this here
welcome everyone mr. Simon Says play
Halo one of these days we will so yeah
yes today's bloodstains and you guys are
gonna enjoy it's really nice it looks
great
Oh move your mic to where the front is
facing you yeah there we go okay go and
I'm also just very loud so it's kind of
bad when I talk and it's and it's real
loud and then they can't hear you
but yeah so we're jumpy and thank you
Ben and everybody and welcome back we
see crime in the house that's so chilled
you guys hear me now I can hear you a
little better but literally or my his
mic is all the way up I'm just too loud
just as the fires at the Laki eruption I
always feel like I should be quiet
during the cutscenes I just talked to
you can't help it you're excited
fearing the rise industrialism and
abandoned by their wealthy patrons
through recondite arts the alchemists
had created so uh you know this game is
definitely like sort of like has a lot
of the same style on like sort of the
tone of like a Castlevania experience
like oh the music sounds like something
is it's interesting seeing this sort of
come back to like you know this sort of
style of Castlevania sort of come back
it's not Castlevania the church you know
it I'll be honest I've been yearning for
something like this you know like you
know just something like Metroid that
Metroidvania style like you know action
RPGs just like sing you know dozens of
hours in just like finding a lute so
this is actually gonna be pretty
exciting because this year first I'm
actually playing this one right but
you've played all of the other babies
right um I played a little bit of this
okay some time ago because of course
this game has been in development quite
a while so I played in earlier build but
this is actually my first time playing
the full game I'm pretty much going into
it a little bit but yes I played plenty
of previous Castlevania games my
favorite being Symphony of the Night
names
yes that's everyone's like that seems to
be everyone who's absolutely favorite I
have seen a lot of it and you know a lot
of my friends loved that game too so I'm
always watching them play well you know
when it comes to games like this I kind
of enjoy watching people better than me
play it because you know they're not
easy easy so I'm excited to check it out
and everybody in the chat saying they
remember you from the DMC DLC
playthrough so what's up Jonathan thanks
for that and 70s gamer says he's new
here so welcome we're here every day at
11 a.m. every weekday sorry so yeah come
back next time and saw some people still
mentioning halo halo will definitely be
played more here as long as I'm around
but not today we played it in the past
for go check out those VOD later if you
want Co but you know infinite got
announced you three will already been
announced but they showed off a little
bit more so get this started Miriam in
johannes so hard to believe I wouldn't
even be alive if not for him I know I
know how you feel but the facts are a
parent and the hell he endured ten years
ago would break the best of souls Miriam
I want you to know that I'm sorry
so heavy already from the beginning I
was their transgression not yours you
you always took care of us
quality the voice acting is not so bad
either
yeah pretty impressed previous
Castlevania games have been I love
symphony of the night but it's got some
really bad is responsible for the
summoning a monster hey that's like
we're like ahead of their time means it
was like you always save them just out
of nowhere now right I mean they
definitely tried though they did yes
indeed shoutouts to all the first time
watchers here you know it's pretty
exciting since you know I just started
working a couple months ago and I've
been seeing a lot of new faces and I
also feel like a new face sometimes so
welcome welcome
shades samurai is looking forward to
picking up blood-stained from what I've
seen it does look really fun I watched
John Luke playing some of it yesterday
and some videos is pretty cool I also
saw online some of my friends who were
like longtime castlevania fans that you
know they're still the same type of
movement options so you know where they
hop backwards and use that as the
movement instead it's so pretty cool the
new dragon 91 says ah I waited for his
gift is slush such a long time it's
beautiful
greetings from Argentina welcome welcome
and I appreciate your excitement I
really like this yes please Ben halo
community Fridays let me know hop in the
squad with you guys the next order of
business is to he is literally shaking
his boots shaking in his boots
easy lightening legs oh wait
some mystical stuff uninvited cool
scraping across my bones the demons
power has been forcibly bonded the
strength you gain from it is undeniable
but eventually I thought the procedure
you discovered halted the corruption it
did that doesn't guarantee you'll be
safe if you start absorbing shards in
massive quantities oh boy better than
anyone
Oh famous last words they're going to
need all the power I can get if I run
into trouble you can help me you've done
it the fool he'll do it again well
alright
she's so nonchalant in the matter just
promise you won't push yourself I know
he was like an agony but that was
amazing oh no it's getting jacked away
inside the demons from the castle must
have infested the ship then they can
help me wake up these muscles of mine
I'll wipe the deck with them
she's got hot will you to play vtm - oh
I'm sorry
what is that abbreviations I I do not
know who but you know if it's something
coming out or something new or something
updated I'm pretty sure we'll play we
try to stay on top of the the new goods
I don't look fine now I do have some
wicked Majesty to hold my hand up to
it's about this game see I released on
PC ps4 and Xbox one on the 18th which
was yesterday
so brand-new and then on the switch on
the 25th which is Tuesday
who you can save 10% on this game right
now on Steam so with the 10% off on
Steam it's $35.99
and then $39.99 for ps4 and I'm assuming
it might be the same for other places
[Music]
ooh but they have some special editions
also that look pretty nice so yeah we're
looking at about 35 to 40 across all
platforms some platforms have a sale
some don't so check it out take
advantage this is this a sequel now I
don't think this is a sequel to
Castlevania it's kind of its own series
it's just made by the same some of the
same people from castlevania is a
spiritual successor yes so it has a
completely separate story
[Music]
[Music]
yeah huh there we go that was he and
everybody was like yeah we can use it
again it's quite a fan of this hey
that's cool though they brought it back
Jensen said he got it for 35 on Amazon
so yeah shop around you guys save some
money we got some deals going on already
welcome back Errol he also confirmed
spiritual sequel can make this jump I
believe yeah Ben was telling us he was
trying to get to the first beat the
first boss and it wasn't working out
that's that's the first goal of the day
defeat the first boss
Errol says I hope to get this game soon
there are just too many other games this
summer it's so true there's just so many
games coming out I mean it's amazing it
really is but it starts to make you pick
and choose you know because games are
expensive these days
[Music]
surprise I really do like palette looks
like it still keeps the same essence but
you know brings in the modern era of
graphics
[Music]
Adam says he's already played so many
hours so yeah I've been hearing from
almost everyone that's played it so far
that they really liked it and oh yeah
Gil vana ray says there is a prequel
though not Castlevania it's
blood-stained curse of the moon in 8-bit
style so if that's what you guys are
referring to then he asked this is a
sequel to that one
[Music]
nice big ol couch I'm a big fan of like
the really stylish like a source 8.0
yeah
all right Charles well thanks for tuning
in glad your updates almost done press
some buttons man I definitely respect
that
it's like they're power-ups but they
look so painful so it's also scary
Harvey asks what console is this on
right now is on ps4 PC and Xbox and it's
coming to switch on just a Tuesdays so
it's gonna be everywhere
like fine you stay up in the wall
[Music]
oh thank little hit-and-run oh dang oh
nice not personally this was always a
game that all of my friends loved and
then when we play they just play through
it and I never got to play like check
this out this parts so cool but I'd
really only played like or watch most of
70 in the night so it's kind of cool all
my friends who love something and I are
so excited about this games you
[Music]
something spotty at filling they say
give you an idea vertical
[Music]
Oh get away from me and squid
[Music]
all right have fun Charles enjoy the
game glad you stopped by before your
game finished download and hey if
anybody else wants to download this game
go for it Google now I'm just gonna have
a sit
[Music]
we've got one one coin we're rich nice
that's how they know how iconic it was
that they created trophies and stuff
like that
Jensen says how does the game feel so
far great I mean it's got some mechanics
that are very similar to full burst one
of the early GPA which also had a
mechanic
houses gave me some tasty jams as
expected yeah seriously I was just like
setting up to stream and we're in like
the main menu and I was like groovin I
the music up so loud oh yeah I see it oh
he's back
[Music]
Kalyanam really like maybe there was a
way to get to it just from this site but
doesn't look like it in the map how does
the other character play and well we
just started this renders so yeah that
was at that point just yet but no
worries we still got plenty around
I was talking to just splashing up any
bits of calamari oh okay
whoa and a helm break your head
[Music]
yes please once you look at the move
you're like oh yeah I know at that move
I know that no I don't think this is the
bus every day pretty quickly
is that
[Music]
he's pointy damaging yourself is like
hitting him nice he crumbles he crumbles
it's such like a classic style like jump
over push this block oh the whip someone
was just talking about the whip O'Brien
said the whip in the first area is
horrible to use I feel like that was a
trick
yeah I want a whip um uh get wit super
active feeling it back to the claim
where have you ever seen that anime
claim why it's pretty good I mean they
didn't they needed to make more of it
but it was really good it was basically
about all these like female warriors
with swords who were mixed with like
this type of demon that was in that
world they're trying to defeat them but
they to make them warrior that could
fight against them they were like
half-breed so they were like half female
half the thing was called yo-yo ma and
yeah it was pretty cool I really liked
it it was like super gruesome too they
just chopped people without chop them in
half but they all had giant swords like
that so that's probably why it's pretty
cool though if you guys do end up
checking it out I apologize in advance
because you're gonna love it and then
it's gonna end really abruptly with no
closure and you're gonna be like what
the heck yeah exactly like it got really
really good and then total clicking here
oh is this the boss oh no it doesn't
maybe like they have matching tattoos so
I don't know if this is a friend or not
it doesn't oh he didn't how does it not
after all the since humans are humanely
sins once again creating stellar plot
lines
[Music]
oh boy oh nice got some clean wear fins
in the Chad I appreciate that
Shin says is there a way to move her
faster or is that her movement speed
throughout the game well still very
early on but like potentially you could
you know make it faster hmm okay
yeah we're still early early on in so
we're gonna try to get as far as we can
and maybe we'll come across some buffs
but yeah yeah this is nonsense
oh this is her brother from the
beginning of the story I gotcha I gotcha
I gotcha okay how does Miriam winter
derpy Otto
she looks great she's also been stabbed
by sharks multiple times
Brennan hostage she says sorry if I
butchered your name huge tip hit all the
walls that's right it's a it's a very
common Castlevania true
sometimes you will find perfectly good
meat that's like weird and a cool little
like hidden tip at the seams I know
Miriam I tired
oh geez geez Big Brother you're here to
kill me aren't you
then first prove you can find me along
the way choice but to absorb sounds and
avail yourself of the powers of him come
and claim me and my brother had problems
but nothing quite on this level
boss fight alright
this must be the boss see if I can do it
I did say air so I can exactly oh dang
she is massive oh okay so the tentacles
thanks leo
they kind of hurt you but it's fine
looking some good damage Oh a lady that
moving the ship I feel like when I'm
hungry my stomach looks exactly like
that she is kind of fabulous so like I
know she's supposed to be this crazy
evil monster but it's gorgeous
we have some some items we can eat for
health nice okay we still got a good
amount of health so yeah we need to use
them now got some some squids oh it's
the atom so there's some stone mass and
other Jojo references exactly Bob Jones
confirmed
I've never conspired to kill my brothers
but never will I love him very much
okay great we're healthy again
yeah we dodged all of that she must have
some serious heartburn or something for
all this because an iron is dodging the
tentacle slice a rising limb that we
need in one of those
[Music]
use the powers Szczesny a dragon
[Music]
jet maximum asks is this out already or
just the Kickstarter copies no this is
indeed out and available now and will
also be out on switch on Tuesday ooh
level up and we're going to do more
damage oh nice
let's go
that still gives me every time I'm like
oh wait she's still alive was like no
you need at that
oh nice we get our own tentacles now
easy peasy
good job Alessandra bin says I didn't
even know you could hit her when she's
over the ship your boys learning hey
this is why we brought all isandro to
play this top tier gameplay for you guys
[Music]
it's too tempting to just like mash
through all of the cutscenes cuz you
start playing and you're like oh and go
back and get stuff or save and whatnot
hcg says which Castlevania does this
game resemble the most
[Music]
but also portrait as well for the main
character okay for similar okay so it's
like a mash uh yeah
got some elements from a variety of
different games which is cool which
means sorry I was reading was hockey
which means that people if you've played
all these any of these other games you
thought you might like this game yep
so shade samory says persia did you say
there was a limited edition when I was
browsing the interwebs I did see that
here let me scroll down to make sure oh
[Music]
maybe it's just a hard case finish it I
don't know if it's in a limited edition
or not but some of these are also eBay
ads so I'm not sure how much I trust
that here let me let me do some further
research
I do see some curse of the moon
collector's edition what else do we go
to I think it's just a steel case copy
I'm not sure if it's an action to Miriam
edition you know who I am and that means
I'm sorry we couldn't get here sooner
Dominica so this is our contact yes but
actually maybe not this guy's looks like
he just made I need one and then put it
up on eBay
he's be on the safe side I'm gonna say
not sure it's you Miriam but thank you
for guiding huh definitely available on
our platforms which is good wouldn't ask
if it wasn't important you should tell
us what's the replayability of this game
well I guess it depends on if you're
like a completionist or two you want to
go back and get everything actually
launched trailer they just showed off
the third character oh cool so is he
like from other other games too or
shovel knight he's been oh cool I guess
cool so maybe we'll see him in gin mill
yeah okay
intention of 14 May then maybe I
wouldn't be surprised if he does show is
there a game smart review for this
shoulders good question right this is
our own personal game play yes this
isn't that this is not a review although
I am enjoying it a lot of people were
really happy with how it turned out
forgive me for skipping any cutscenes
their talks yeah you guys are gonna have
to go buy the game don't want to spoil
too much for you guys and experience it
for yourself
we want to get maximum gameplay out of
our short 90 minutes bad stuffs
happening and we had to help ya TLDR
we're saving the world all right since
this is your first time here yeah Eddie
spaghetti is looking for it on switch
but that's not till Tuesday so it's not
out on switch yet but soon very soon I
have made arrangements so you can buy
and sell items here Shannon says now
Nintendo does need to make a proper 2d
Metroid Metroid Prime 1 & 2 are amazing
but we need a new 2d Metroid for sure
yeah a lot of people seem really happy
with the Samus Returns which they
released I agree I remember watching
like a super old
like you tube video and it was like
Samus versus Master Chief yeah I was
like a whole series it was exactly super
toy I believe the creator of that series
went on to make the RBW I oh that would
make sense
I just remember watching him like such a
long time ago I think it was the coolest
thing ever and you think back to stuff
like that nowadays I'm like man people
are so ahead of their time shade says
that our stream ends people in this chat
are polite and go GameSpot thank you we
try to have fun and play some games and
enjoy our mornings with you guys and you
guys seem to enjoy it with us feels so
much appreciated geez girl trying to get
the shop oh snap even monsters have to
take their selfies too graphic to put it
more plainly it allows me to capture
images of real-life landscapes people
really can I try it I know this house
very unfortunately I need I'll see if I
can find it for the love of the selfie
she's gonna go find what she needs to
take this photo I respect it
all right that's right so chilled we're
a cool kind of people here all of us all
around everybody you included
condolences
what's yours
Miriam well anyone else here looking
forward to cyber but cyberpunk 2077 all
of us I'm sure it looks really good I'm
definitely looking forward to it and
Keanu oh my gosh yeah for sure have to
marvel at the church's resources look at
what they've provided for us I know it's
a tall Church in the workshop is take
materials you bring me and transmute
them into new items but the alchemy is
easier to show you then explain all
right makes them what are we transmuting
this time I like crafting I that's like
one of my favorite things to do in games
yeah cuz then I always hoard all the
stuff
I don't know sometimes games with like
tedious tasks like that or like a little
therapeutic I used to play this one game
called kingdom for calf Ling's like all
the time and yeah it's literally just
this little game and you like land in
this town of tiny people and you're like
a giant and they think you're like a god
so they help build this town with you
and you know you assign certain people
to like chop wood and then the sign is
certain people to mine rocks and stuff
like that and then you build houses and
it's a girl's little town it's like so
silly but you know games like that are
fun I like crafting I like building
[Music]
crafting and cooking yeah Brennan I like
that also Fanning in a cooking mama and
stuff like that but games where you can
like craft stuff and then go and cook it
that's pretty fun as you go I mean I
feel like a lot of games implement stuff
like that nowadays crime don't you dare
judge me for playing Catholics all right
it's great man these guys are drunk
they're just up there wobbling around
we got some some pistols yeah I picked
this up really yeah nice we got infinite
ammo that's that's OD I like it seems to
be the fast travel mechanic so hey red
room stayed green rooms fast travel Oh
snake doesn't do damage I guess it would
be okay if it if it hurt really bad
oh snap
another shard
the other building really I really like
you like you know you remember playing
all those roller coaster tycoons and
city builders man city builders are so
fun I don't know why I just really like
building cities except when my city is
like in debt and there's a lot of
pollutions that's not fun I always start
over if it gets that point but my most
recent city I built is in pretty good
shape
some people are worried about how this
games gonna play on switch but I don't
think it's gonna be bad
some people said there's gonna be at
30fps but I don't think it's bad we
actually saw the game running
I hope it's improved the drawbridge oh
yeah you gotta go down I see I see
ooh okay guilty pleasure games that's a
good question do you have any games
that's like a guilty pleasure I'm sorry
nothing yeah fine I play some pretty
wild games sometimes
[Music]
I don't know I never really feel guilty
for any of the games might have known
achievement unlocked I want to hear some
of y'all's guilty pleasure games to you
because like this is a interesting
question it's a good question so thank
you crying for that huh guilty pleasure
games what game and I play them
embarrass is healthy wisely I mean I
guess for a while it was marvel because
of you people are hating on us but I'm
never guilty for playing marvel let me
think
there's gotta be some games out there I
guess I don't wake Kingdom for cufflinks
is kind of like that but I still really
like like okay so that's not so bad oh
did you like it it was good but I felt
dirty play it's just so like ridiculous
with its microtransactions
oh I never really spent any money on it
was just like why am i supporting this
rate right
Diablo style like a beat em up game
that's pretty cool then yeah I think to
be honest guilty pleasure games would
probably be something mobile like like
sugar crush or something like you know
it's technically a game and you know
when I lived in New York oh my goodness
I played so much candy crush games you
know it's like a train game so I would
say mobile games are probably a good
guilty-pleasure game that's awesome I
mean they look like suspicious yeah for
sure like I know skull girls they had
something similar people who like help
the game and then they had hand-drawn
avatars of themselves in various stages
and stuff like that so that's pretty
awesome
owls mood says I want to play it yeah
heck yeah
get the game it's out now Grimes says
candy crush this is just a pleasure game
can't be stopped yeah I haven't really
played it much you know I never really
had a nice enough phone to truly enjoy
mobile gaming but now I do and I still
live in that mindset of like my phone's
not good enough for this which is why I
don't play pokemon go my phone wasn't
even compatible with that game and so I
didn't get into it you know I missed the
hype and now I do have it and I'm like
ah I felt like I'm too far behind people
have like a bajillion Pokemon already
[Music]
yeah at the time it felt like sort of
this flashes just like yeah like it
wasn't gonna last but it's still around
yeah I'm just glad people have gotten
better at like not playing while they're
driving so close so child says that's
his guilty pleasure areas Pokemon go
jd's I felt like a Philby street urchin
playing elder scroll blades why man
[Music]
I would say I definitely have like a
guilty pleasure of going onto each and
every like platform like whether its PSN
or Xbox Live I'm like all right what
games are free I mean I just want to
download them and play them I don't care
what it is it's free and that's all that
matters I love that they have those
deals you know back in the day they
didn't have as many free games Oh big ol
tall dude what he's got like a auto auto
sword chainsaw man that was that was
wild that is some advanced technology
for this guy
oh you leveled up so maybe scene there's
a boss possibly so far we've been even
am pretty well here about Alessandro is
crushing it
jaelyn says I need a hula counter right
at least 878 days I know
[Music]
[Music]
okay my diary found the diary got it
have you got a chance to play 100 versus
one what is that oh we're just swimming
in a pool of blood and we come out
spotless whatever fabric that dress is
made out of I need it because I spilled
food on myself way too much and that
would be useful tech Auto chests on
mobile super fun Oh welcome back kekeke
okami i remember you because i said your
name right last time I've been hearing a
lot about Auto chess I never actually
played it but I do also know a few
people who are definitely addicting
Tony Turner says what is this game it is
blood stain ritual of the Knights and it
just came out yesterday on ps4 Xbox and
PC and then on Tuesday it will be out on
the switch so check it out ooh is it
boss time
[Music]
alfrid
oh not last time they know each other
they're old friends of an apprentice
should have stayed out of this column
johannes a fool he's been helping us out
will not be defending my actions to you
I'm here for the book jebal has the book
what are you talking about if you don't
already know then let us keep it that
way
oh man rude he was like I heard you were
talking trash about me say it to my face
saying he didn't even answer his
question that's how much he doesn't
respect him and then he just runs away
yeah I mean I do love how skipping
cutscenes can lead to unintentional you
never in a lot
especially when they like barely started
or start speaking yeah for those of you
just tuning in this is made by some of
the same creators of Castlevania so if
it seems very familiar in style that is
why they have so very good game
regardless of the fact and if you enjoy
those games which definitely check this
out because there'll be another addition
to your series oh my goodness
jumping attacks and everything
[Music]
yeah a big door it was like all
intimidating-looking and we just opened
the easy-peasy
pretty far the math is getting smaller
because you wouldn't lock my room's
[Music]
flying pigs I love it so much
oh dang there's a lot going on here and
he got fat he's so adorable
Brandon says dream school girls and no
stress we will see that cake is so cute
yes I love him Leah will beat goodbye
thank you thank you for the chard
[Music]
crime says a library what a fancy name
garden of silence because remembering
that stupid show on MTV called silent
library yes it was so silly vaguely was
there like a Japanese bird I knew it
like most of the crazy game shows we
have in America or based off of a
crazier version from Japan's amore
bow rate anarchist thanks for tuning in
peace out homey and come back next time
yeah silent library was insane and
hilarious like I would always tell my
friends if we ever ended up on that show
we'd all lose cuz I laugh at everything
even if it's not funny I'm very much a
nervous laughter and just like a
constant
laughter like we're currently playing on
PC forum next channel games who asked
I love these buying bag like they're hit
their little nose Wiggles to they're
just so cute
I don't know stomach
we had a dramatic death exactly shame
it's like something the other night even
though it's not part of the Castlevania
series it'll be the same experience oh
dang oh that hurt Johannes whip us
something up he was here too he was just
showing up to talk sit home boy no
stranger danger no thanks please you
know maybe on the level alright alright
you do it but we don't recommend those
at home if a strange coachman asks you
to take ride somewhere we do not
recommend you get into the vehicle I
need a giant Wow okay there's definitely
a boss soon's that we're getting this
giant Han from
how's he gonna offer a ride and then
just tell us you need something else hey
we're flying gigs yeah that guy's pretty
big like I'm gonna get his hands hang
out robbing it over here J says good
evening were you from J it's pretty
early for us it means almost noon right
shade
he's like looks to friend me think I'll
ever buy a ps5 when pigs fly me hens and
bloodstains exactly it's the best
counter like you can't even use that
analogy anymore
I remember for like when I was like 11
or 12 they tried to trick you I got a
pair of vans for Christmas that had
little like pictures of flying pigs it
was great I loved it
so the Barbados crystal is super Opie is
so sleepy marabou oh we're back to
library did we get the giant hands true
era
they're so cute yes they are
there's moose see those cubes like you
know when Yoshi that's good will stomp
they thought that move it's so great him
I'm mentally preparing for this next
boss battle
lavalla ila snap all right we're gonna
be super buff for when we fight this
this boss Holly made a little squeaky
noise to all isandro stop hurting my
friends they always come back
yeah
oh they all got you again
they were like codons like bounce off of
him
they were like having a conversation
then you walked in oh my god oh my god
the arrows in your head seems great
parading closer we are including close
dojo games if you want this game on the
switch it comes out on Tuesday my
friends so not too far away well he just
walked through you and damage you we got
all types of weapons now all we got his
sword oh my god that's awesome you think
you're hardcore buddy well we got one of
those too oh wow he just has the pokey
armor he's like a cactus so dramatic the
way he does this is actually useful
travel yeah cuz we're close to the save
room over here very nice very nice
take a seat on the couch real quick all
right saboom we're healthy we're ready
for this next boss are we near the story
do we need to buy some stuff nice this
little girl shine and told us to run our
pockets last time flattery
that's the first technique of a Salesman
that blouse looks great on you you
should buy it I'm not gonna lie that's
worked on me once or twice okay
sometimes you'll be on the fin so you'd
be like do I like this shirt and then
they'll just walk out and be like that
looks so good on you and I'm like you're
right I went to had a very good friend
of mine gets duped into buying like this
$200 coat that made him look like a
rockstar pirate but thank you
you know she got the sale so I was
pretty good
I'm gonna put your name but lag Ruiz
says they love the game
they had their doubts but damn it's good
reminds them so much of sympathy in the
night but what did they expect it gave
me dick oh yeah definitely still here
some really good things about the game
since yesterday and even before people
were like all can't we please come out
yeah alright time to fast travel on back
we're healthy we're stocked up
we got chainsaw sword it's super
effective weaker but the multiple did
got some good range right well thank you
cheesecake
you're a breath of fresh air I hope you
have a great day see ya I mean we're all
here having fun playing some games and
just hanging out I personally like you
know being able to have GameSpot live
every day because it's nice to just like
take some time and play and hang out
with you guys and like talk to everybody
knew that shows up and everybody who
returns I think it's really cool you
guys are a great community and we get to
check out all these cool games oh there
was another safe hey it's fine we got to
go to the store too
was it was not man that sort is awesome
oh he's a silhouette Wow
that ghastly air about you you reek of
sorcery char binder and what am I to
make of you oh snap the reveal he looks
so cool though oh dang oh dang thing
gets ooh Oh with the highrise win for
hell breaker
ding and he's got a grappling hook oh my
lord we yeah we need some Hales
oh man
yeah he's best oh boy
nice the cross under like I'm fighting
him he's got this goes for the teleport
oh wow you've lost your attack oh it's
with punish oh the treats were not in
our favor
dang that guy was was salty he
definitely had a bone to pick with us
but it's ok we saved right outside do we
get all of our goods back ok good
[Music]
all right it's this story it's still the
optimalsort here made the hardest lead
on you ever can it work
wow the range on that board Oh Annie's
like got armor you still swinging
through your time geez alright alright
it's fine you know that was just a it
was just a that was a download round so
you're just kidding uses pattern X Enix
says pro tip always dodge frontward
developers enjoy pushing punishing
scared players not scared I'm scared
maybe it's affecting you by proxy I got
rid of the fun weapon then now I'm going
gosh yeah sounds good are the items in
the scarfs of lard that is that just
cosmetic or those give you buffs yeah
yep
oh nice nice that is just straight up
like I like that's so much alright I'm a
sucker for a customization I really am
stop right there
oh man yeah see what your head so was
one of his so we're gonna have to out
space him
taunting your frozen its dodge dodge
again a lot of rain for the fireball wow
that did so much damage okay I'm just
gonna equate all his myths or Virgil's
news and we should be fine oh you trying
to wrap it / you looking good here he's
getting molds right now oh okay it's
yellow teal no we're good we're doing
really good this time
nice name he's downloaded now we know
your moves oh oh wow wow that was cheap
he is getting more powerful I'm not
taking that beat bro this is on Steam no
reason
oh my gosh he must be close to death
been out playing him all wow he - back
explosion there we go boom boom boom
your your achievements called Samurai
Shodown that's awesome
oh man shades so sorry to hear about
your equipment getting damaged this is
actually the second playable character
ah that's dope
and he's also voiced by a David Hayter
Oh
oh so someone made a pun earlier they
were like I hater this next boss what is
the difference the alchemists were the
gunmen the shard binders the gun all
must be dismantled so yeah you have to
let his sins go all the way there the
powers of hell and must pay for it but
Miriam is not like them she is fighting
for us at great personal risk really you
forget how many of our friends perished
for similarly miss placing their faith
he doesn't really cool though
undo I look as weak look closer
that was bored with her anyway
dang the trash talks you need to put a
stop to Alfred and I will but you listen
to me i buy good on you shade for
finding the silver linings and stay out
of my son upgraded equipment can hold me
to my word Dominique
but don't presume to tell me what else I
can Cardinal says the voice acting in
this game is much better than he thought
it was gonna be so yeah we agree this
walks away so edgy
all right let's great we had definitely
save we're like blinking red it would be
a shame if we randomly got hit by an
arrow before we saved oh it's okay he's
not Hawkeye he done has those skills oh
my gosh Christ he's like blocking the
save room get out of here bro I know how
are you doing on time we aren't good we
still got 19 minutes left of the stream
today we've defeated two bosses don't
know if we'll run into the next one in
time but it's been a pretty solid run so
far
and we got to hear snake so I think we
definitely succeeded in today's run X
Enix s the cosplay material from this
game will be legendary
right I'm saying I want to see some of
these cosplays already let suddenly
become something oh snap HP mess
even though oh wait did it fill up the
bar overall or just gave us myself but
yeah when I started seeing new games and
stuff I always look forward to seeing
like how people cosplay characters
especially the really really good
cosplayer is oh we got a gold one this
time
Henry K says is this game easy if you're
familiar with Castlevania games like
this of a symphony other night then
you'll feel right at all in terms of
like the challenge you know it's
starting out that's pretty cool on the
developers part that you know they made
something familiar but still challenging
for people who've been playing games
like this you know their whole lives
pretty much
so that's awesome
oh snap
got Wicked Witch of the West old man
he's like Waldo Flash Wicked Witch /
like Freddy Krueger
oh man that monster looked crazy - he's
like a wheel I bet you that's super fun
like hey we have to create some some
enemies they all need to look absolutely
him and do a bunch of crazy stuff that's
your job like this is a lion demon lion
tail legs wheel guy who's out of that
and give them a raise because that's the
stuff nightmares and also very creative
oh wow yeah these have to be people who
are contributors to the Kickstarter
farm the barber enemy for one of the
best weapons in the game is so sleepy
marabou the more I see this enemy the
more creepy he becomes skill shard oh
snap
boo yeah still so much stuff to unlock I
mean we've only been playing for like an
hour and 15 minutes but look how much
stuff there is unlock I like games like
that one game I really really liked that
you know as far as gameplay style is
nothing like this but in terms of like
how character looks which is really cute
I don't know if anybody has ever played
resonance of fate I really really loved
that game and a lot of the customizable
stuff in my game is really cool too yeah
there's just so much stuff - all day
[Music]
yeah she gave you the backhand but yeah
that kind of reminds like there's a lot
of stuff so I'm walking that game too
and I really really love that game I
played it for such a long time and I
still felt like I didn't even unlock
like half of the stuff in my hand so
most RPGs are like that
[Music]
possibly sleepy what's the name of the
of the weapon you're speaking of so we
can try to use it on the street it's
just an item oh okay okay
Oh bin said that wall cracked all the
way to the right
[Music]
[Music]
gen-i CUSO is watching this makes him
miss the old Castlevania a lot that's so
cool you can definitely tell these are
people who contributed to the
Kickstarter so awesome oh he's so creepy
all his legs and then they just fall off
it has two drops a razor blade and the
weapons oh okay the weapon has a high
drop rate though gotcha
thank you for the tips and tricks here
are you guys
all right so crazy lady up here yeah
let's bring Baldo down here so we don't
disturb her just rips Oh
crude oil rude okay she's awake she
looks pretty cool though you know she's
Oh Pete get out of here
get out of here you dumb mentor oh my
goodness no no we don't have anything oh
my gosh oh my gosh she has to be close
to death no we need a Patronus just says
when's marvel good question man and
they're talking about Avengers but yeah
which also has x-men in it right right
which is exciting news in general it's
all around the board exciting stuff
welcome back shade didn't miss too much
we are indeed though trying to take out
this diamond to our lady we have up here
she's been cursing us it's been it's
been rough she took us out twice that's
okay Lina learning the patterns and all
that goodness that creepy lion like guy
here so creepy
[Music]
I'm also very big Harry Potter nerd so
yep that's the thing anywhere I can fit
in a Harry Potter reference I usually do
all right let's get this lady you got
this you got this curse cuts your HP in
half so let's let's not get cursed
oh my goodness oh my god
at first I was like okay it only did
four damage and then a hundred and forty
five damage later this is where we are
yeah just go back to save get oh you
left him down there earlier doer like
whatever weird leg lion we're just gonna
pass you up it came back to bite us in
the butt its darned a mentor lady up
here
probably we need to maybe level up once
or twice more all the dog oh she has a
ton of HP so hit and run got it
have I passed the test on the Potter
site I'm trying to remember if the one I
took was an official Potter more water I
know I took one that was like 50
questions long and I think I I almost
got it perfect it was like 48 out of 50
questions and the two I missed I was
like really mad a mistake if I felt like
they were trick question
but you know it's still pretty good but
I don't remember if that was an official
Pottermore won or not it might have just
been one of that you know how facebook
is oh we woke her on accident
oh I said I see I see
oh the Dementors like twice your guys's
level in the past a dead end behind her
yeah we'll just leave her over there for
now
Oh Dave he really is like get out of
your leg lyin I go it was absolutely in
love with flying pigs and I freaking
hate these legs I am so much they're so
weird looking
[Music]
please
oh I thought it went all the way
underneath to do a live test oh boy I
should try and put me on the spot no I'd
be too so down for that though I really
do
ooh it's so cute buddy's evil as hell oh
my gosh
I I wonder what level this kitty it's a
meatball wasn't that bad at all
kitty ears oh my gosh please put those
on really see if it's good buffs yeah
look +5 defense this game is already so
amazing adorable thing woke up this okay
of that that thing was really
weird-looking too
yes the same powers mr. cat I would be a
great addition to Slytherin are you
crazy
I'm a Gryffindor I would never be a
Slytherin oh that's a nice mess
[Music]
a demon of wait I'm a good killer barber
a good know about all those sounds
suspicious the only way my curse will be
lifted is if I barber my way through 666
different hairstyles Wow I don't just
make the hairstyles up then love little
off here or there won't be laughing oh
my god that is getting added to my
vocabulary for the rest of my life yes
yes yes
yeah Sweeney Todd for real you look like
you could rip me into a hundred pieces I
really could all right you have a deal
oh my gosh
his name is Todd not Sweeney Todd oh my
goodness
new hairstyle oh that's nice and you
have costume colors are OMG hmm what
color do we want it clashes with our
outfit unless we can change our outfit
to red see this is where you don't want
me to help you because we will spend all
the rest of our time customizing is
character this is awesome though really
cool
yes matches ears matches the hair I like
it yeah
give me your alien colors - that's
awesome
he's like slice except your hair got
longer instead of shorter those are some
magical scissors so you have to change
your hairstyle 666 times for him to be
free I'm sure someone will actually do
that to see what special hair curse is
lifted but I'll stick around
Omega
wow that hurts they need to get their
animals on a leash all right we've got
three minutes left let's see if we can
find this boss I don't know if I run
into it
got any target here's what I've turned
up on the monsters
good work oh snap Oh interesting help
side quests gotcha
[Music]
what's more scary is if the boss finds
you in three minutes yeah pretty much
but yeah I think this is a perfect save
spots and that basically wraps up our
stream for it's a day but we had a lot
of fun playing and kind of showing off
the game to use eyes this game is out
and available right now on Xbox ps4 and
on PC and on Tuesday comes out on switch
and thank you for the expert gameplay
Alessandro and for joining us today and
tomorrow is gonna be fun because we're
gonna be playing some Street Fighter 5
with Ricky or et is at the Cena Xfinity
smart home so it's gonna be really fun
and then this Friday
we're playing Crash Team Racing with the
community well not me specifically but
Ben and John Luke will be here so if you
guys want to check out either of those
games please tune in and we're here
every weekday at 11 a.m. so looking
forward to seeing you guys next time and
peace out